we are so happy to be here but I feel
yeah mm I have to take my shoes off girl
me too
I've been wearing these shoes since 11
o'clock this morning how long you been
wearing your shoes thanks the Critics
Choice Awards oh well I got blisters
bubbling up on the bottom of my foot or
on my pinky toe fella Oh
[Applause]
we are we are so happy to be here but a
little nervous too because a few years
ago people were saying that Oscars were
so white and since then some real
progress has been made
mmm but we when we came out together we
know some of you were thinking are the
Oscars two black men but we just want to
say don't worry there are so many more
white people to come so many we just
came from backstage and there are tons
of them back then and not just movie
stars there are white people walking
around with hair fed white people with
clipboard I'm personally not a fan of
white people with clipboards because I'm
always wondering what are they writing
down about me oh yeah oh yeah when
they're like I'm sorry you're not on the
list and they didn't check all the pages
I'm like hey white dude with the
clipboard check all the pages oh and
what about when they on the hair thing
and you're like who would I talk it's
sometimes I would say are you talking to
me oh you're not talking you want me to
wait I'm sorry
okay Kim who's Kim I don't know but it
feels like I'm in a department store
[Applause]
guys enough about our personal issue we
are presenting two awards tonight
documentary short subjects and
live-action short film
here are the nominees for Best
Documentary short subjects Edith and
Eddie Laura chuck away and Thomas Lee
right heaven is a traffic jam on the 405
frank stifle heroine Elaine McMillian
Sheldon and her and Sheldon
knife skills Thomas Lennon traffic stop
Kate Davis and David Heil Brunner
[Music]
hi Meryl I want you to be my mama one
day just one day let's get this money
girl okay documentaries short subject
the winner is heaven is a traffic jam on
and nomination for Christ I
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my kids are hosting an Oscar party which
I think probably just got a lot louder
this is amazing for so many reasons the
source of this film is the source of
everything it's gone well for me for the
last 40 years it's my wife BJ Dockweiler
it's a team who casey price Paula maroon
Misaki Okochi
Ben Marius thank you for giving the film
which I couldn't - Mindy who's somewhere
up there Mindy I'm really proud of this
but I always knew but I always knew that
the only reason people would care about
it is because we all care about you
thank you
[Applause]